well those countries around the world
grapple with the corona virus pandemic
there are growing calls to address
conditions in refugee camps in Europe
experts fear that a virus outbreak is
imminent in overcrowded camps on the
Greek islands social distancing is
almost impossible and poor hygiene could
lead to the virus spreading
uncontrollably one woman in a camp near
Athens recently tested positive
activists say the European Union must do
more to provide safe housing and
conditions over your Hansen is the EU
commissioner for Home Affairs with
migration being one of her key areas to
focus she joins me now from Brussels
commissioner welcome and thank you what
are you going to do it's a question that
haunts many people at the moment what
are you going to do if there's a corona
virus outbreak in one of the badly
overcrowded Greek migrant camps we have
to avoid that we have to do everything
to avoid that crisis to happen and
that's why we are working very hard now
to set up an emergency response action
plan together with the Greek authorities
and this is now in place so what we
should do now is to immediately evacuate
the most vulnerable individuals out of
these camps so that they can be secured
in hotel rooms or apartment and not
being affected if the virus break out in
these camps and also supporting with
medical equipment medical staff and
other kind of measures on that we now
put being make available for the Greek
authorities and for IOM and UNHCR that
we are working close with to deal with
this situation
so it's now been weeks ago a group of EU
countries agreed to take in hundreds of
uniike unaccompanied minors from the
migrant camps you're saying now that
that action plan will swing into
immediate effect to evacuate those those
kids emergency plan is to evacuate the
most vulnerable old people sick people
out of the camps to safe areas like
hotel rooms
that are available right now outside the
camps so they will not stay in these are
and conditions in the camps the
relocation of the unaccompanied minors
is also going quite well we have eight
members days that are ready to welcome
these children and I do hope that the
first relocation will take place in the
coming week so that they are now being
transferred to transit centers well
they're also being tested for the corona
visors and virus and prepared for the
relocation to these member states that
are welcoming them and for me this is a
very important message of a practic sort
practical solidarity in these times
where we need to lease the pressure on
these overcrowded camps on the islands
so you will ood to it you're preaching
solidarity but why is it being so
difficult to find a solution for the
migrants and refugees who have been
stranded there some of them for years
now since I took office we've been
working working very hard to find a new
dealer migration an asylum that I will
propose soon and I hope that could be
acceptable for all Member States and we
okay also working quite close together
with the Greek government and the Greek
authorities and the UN organizations to
help have better conditions in this
overcrowded camp and to release the
pressure on these camps by relocating
people out of this camp and also to
return people and just finally who then
is actually responsible for the
situation in Greece of course the Greek
government is responsible for a
situation in Greece but they can't act
alone we have to show solidarity and the
European Commission is providing with a
huge lot of money and practical things
with people on the ground helping
working diet day and night to help them
and we're also engaging NGOs and UN
organizations to help them so we they
the Greek authorities and the Greek
government is responsible but we all are
responsible to show
practical solidarity towards Greece and
the migrants in these overcrowded camps
right now over your Hansen EU
commissioner for Home Affairs thank you
so much for your time thank you well
more than half of our half a million
people rather in Europe have now been
affected with the coronavirus European
Union chief is lef underline and other
leaders have criticized the lack of
solidarity and coordination among member
states now found Alliance says the EU
will roll out a huge relief program
comparable to the u.s. rescue fund for
Europe after World War two many are
calling right now for something which is
for this Marshall Plan well I think the
European budget should be the Marshall
Plan we are laying out together as a
European Union for the European people
the Commission will provide loans to
those member states that need them to
strengthen their short time work schemes
these schemes now exist and planned
straight across the European Union well
let's get more from DW Brussels
correspondent Gabe mattes you talk us
through what this new marshal plan
what's in it and for whom well the
short-time unemployment scheme that Olaf
underlined introduced today having a
capacity of a hundred billion euros in
loans from member states is only a small
part of that Marshall Plan and we'll
still have to see what the whole
Marshall plan will look like but the
unemployment scheme she said today is a
second line of defense she wants to
offer to all Member States all member
states have to provide guarantees in
order to participate on in order to
benefit from that scheme but basically
what she has said is that these a short
time on in broadened schemes is
something that member states 18 out of
the 27
already have and she'd like to see it in
all the Member States and what she wants
to provide is basically allowing Member
States did this that's what the scheme
does it allows Member States to reduce
the working hours of people in working
in companies and the state will then
subsidize their salaries now this is a
strong strain on unemployment schemes in
member states and so the the fun she has
created here or she's suggesting that
the you will create then would provide
loans to those member states who have
difficulty and now all of this will be
put in front of finance ministers next
week in order to get the green light and
brings us to the next big question will
this be enough to keep Europe's
economies going look a number of things
are currently being debated for instance
state aid rules have been basically you
have been abolished the state can fund
companies as as much as they want the
very strict financial laws have been
pushed off the table by the Commission
so a lot of measures the European
Central Bank has ingested 750 billion
euros of on the line today set the huge
number to a thousand seven hundred
seventy billion euros have been put in
the table in order to face that crisis
we'll still have to wait and see how
much of that money will actually be
needed for the moment the sign of the
commission the sign that the Commission
wants to send out is that the EU and its
member states take this serious and they
do everything they can in monetary terms
in order to support member states to
prevent them from facing economic
consequences harsh economic consequences
from that crisis ki AAG mattes in
Brussels thank you and here's some more
of the latest developments in the
pandemic Spain's death toll has passed
the 10,000 mark it's Europe's hardest
hit country after italy russia's
President Vladimir Putin has ordered
Russians not to go to work for the rest
of this month to slow the spread of the
outbreak and more evidence of how the
virus is affecting jobs in the US six
and a half million people claimed
unemployment benefits last week and new
record
you